more people are listening to podcasts
than ever before there are more than 500
25,000 to choose from true-crime
podcasts consistently ranked among the
top 50 research shows women
overwhelmingly prefer the murder mystery
genre CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Dana Jacobson went to a live taping of a
true crime podcast in Minneapolis to
find out why
David Dana good morning good morning the
true crime genre exploded in 2014 with
the podcast serial which explored the
guilt of a man who was serving a life
sentence for murder its popularity
actually helped unearth information that
resulted in a new trial for him but it
is not just armchair investigators who
are interested in true crime you are
listening to wine and crime the podcast
where three friends chuck wine chat true
crime and unleash their worst Minnesotan
accents kenyan lang
Amanda Jacobson and Lucy Fitzgerald
friends for more than 20 years and hosts
of the popular podcast wine and crime 56
year old Bovie Bloor was lying face-down
on the floor of the bus bleeding where
they playfully chat about crime over
Cabernet and Chardonnay and then we
thought of wine and crime and we thought
okay well we've got to nap this title
before somebody else does launch the
podcast I have the logo slide that we
always have up that was February 2017 a
year and a half later they get about
500,000 downloads a month and when they
turn the podcast live
they draw fans from across the country
why come tonight fighting crime is one
of my favorite podcast
two lives will serve the longest
sentence because he's the one who
actually used a firearm 85% of their
audience is female a lot of women listen
to true crime because it's a way to kind
of feel like you have control over the
situation even though you don't it took
a moment for beau to realize that both
of his parents were dead why do you
think women are attracted to listening
about true crime we think that it's
because women are so often portrayed as
victims in the media and women in
particular like to think about something
and understand it in order to overcome
like anxieties based around that and
everyone loves a taboo subject yeah and
if you say you don't you're lying wine
and crime is just one of thousands of
true crime podcasts that hit home with a
female audience
at least stay sexy and don't get
murdered arguably the most popular true
crime podcast is my favorite murder
hosted by Karen kill Gareth and Georgia
hardstark
within 5 months of their January 2016
premiere the podcast hit the number one
spot on iTunes obviously my favorite
murder paved the way for so many true
crime podcasts they're massive in our
world and also when we got started it
was easier to launch because we knew
that there was a market for it this is
your chance to tell your hometown or
your favorite murder some fans have even
taken their shared true crime interest
offline to meet up in person when you
come to an event like this after you
know everybody already likes murder so
it's not weird to say it I really like
the angle that the stories are told from
it comes from a place of like protecting
yourself and standing up for yourself
rather than being a victim the podcasts
have also become a support network for
listeners to share their anxieties we
talk about our own mental health
struggles physical health struggles I
mean that stuff comes up all the time I
think it's just relatable my therapist
checks in with me every day reads what I
have to say yeah it's amazing I love it
highly recommend a lot of people have
problems and it's nothing to be hidden
away and be ashamed of it means the
world to us that we are such a part of
people's lives and they find some sort
of comfort and help from our show to
have impact on people like that what
does that mean I think that has been the
biggest surprise of this whole
experience but that's my news it can be
a small part of someone's self-care
that's huge it's huge and wine and crime
will start its first East Coast tour
this November it's one of those where
there's so many offerings out there you
have to find the one that clicks with
you was what we found out the me it was
cereal that's when I first got hooked on
cereal these these guys are doing
something totally do that comedy genre
or try to bring comedy into it it's a
comedy if you can really click with it
but for other people they just want lay
out the murder for me let me think about
that for these women it's more about
hanging out with your girlfriends
drinking wine and talking about it Thank
You Dana